أممم
مفتوحة الأبواب
جاهزة ،
أنت سيد المال يا
رئيس ما هو ردك على
مخطوطة بولتون وهل هذا يزيد
من الفرصة
ولكن هذه خطة مهمة
جدًا للسلام في الشرق الأوسط بغض النظر عن
المكان الذي ذهبت إليه يقولون
إسرائيل والفلسطينيون لديهم
لتحقيق السلام قبل أن تتمكن حقًا من
تحقيق السلام
في الشرق الأوسط ، لذلك عمل الناس
على هذا الأمر
لسنوات عديدة وأعتقد أننا
قريبون نسبيًا ولكن علينا أن نجعل
الآخرين
يوافقون على ذلك أيضًا سأقول العديد
من  وافقت الدول العربية على ذلك
، وأعربت عن اعتقادها بأنها رائعة ، ويعتقدون
أنها بداية كبيرة ،
وأعتقد أنها بداية كبيرة أيضًا ، وأعتقد
أنه أمر رائع إذا تمكنا من تنفيذها ،
فهم يقولون إنها ربما تكون
أصعب صفقة في
أي مكان وأي  لطيفة في عالم
الأعمال
عندما عدت إلى عالم الأعمال
عندما كانت الصفقة صعبة ، كان الناس
يشيرون إليها مازحين لأن هذا أصعب
من اجتماع إسرائيل
والفلسطينيين وهذا ما أنا عليه  لقد سمعت طوال
حياتي ولذا سنرى ما سيحدث لدينا
شيء منطقي جدًا
للجميع ونحن نقدر وجودك هنا والسيد
رئيس الوزراء
العمل الرائع الذي تقوم به شكرًا لك